was genau und herzlich willkommen ja
sehr sympathisch sehe ich gerade leute
was geht herzlich willkommen beim video
shop natürlich geht es gut mir geht es
wunderbar ich hatte nämlich gerade eben
die neuen reifen bekommen für mein auto
und ich freue mich irgendwie voll gerade
weil das ich könnte es schwer das soll
auch heute eigentlich gar nicht das
thema sein das video dazu kommen
eventuell morgen allein würde dem ich
würde kurz entschuldigen so ich hoffe
das ist jetzt auch das richtige paket
fahrzeug noch mit 2 ankommt box boxee
box also wenn das eingestellte ist es
falsch
hier haben wir meinen diesjährigen aber
zu können
ja heute ungefähr vor zwei oder einmal
kam ein video amazon überraschungspaket
400 euro habe ich ziemlich gefeiert und
ich hab mir gedacht ich besorgte mir
passend zur weihnachtszeit die ja
eigentlich noch gar nicht angebrochen
ist aber es gibt halt pins kalender ich
auf jeden fall ein bisschen auch amazon
unterwegs und hab mir insgesamt dann
vier kalender bestellt allerdings war
das hier die teuerste der 50 euro kostet
und zwar ist es ein wirklich sehr sehr
besonderer kalender weil diese in sachen
drin die gibt es in deutschland gar
nicht irgendwie hat amazon da ganz viele
amerikanische süßigkeiten drin verpackt
kein plan und ich würde sagen wir
schauen jetzt mal zusammen nein ich bin
gespannt was ich auf jeden fall noch
sagen wollte wenn ihr bock habt dass sie
auch mal die anderen drei kalendertage
zur schokolade viele verschiedene marken
sind da halt bei ich sag mal so ich will
dann einfach so gucken welche länder
davon ist am coolsten ja wenn ich dazu
ein video machen soll lassen danach um
da bei 10.000 innerhalb von 24 stunden
machen wir das am sonntag oder so jetzt
bin ich mal gespannt was ich hier so
alles finden
und mal schauen wie es schmeckt das
überhaupt 24 19 34 50
wir fangen einfach mal ganz schön an
mitteln hier haben wir ein
schoko bonbon das war die ekligsten
schokolade ich in meinem ganzen leben je
gegessen habe
okay wir gehen mal schnell über zu zwei
vielleicht ist das besser ich sage auch
so voll stolz alles sachen die es nicht
in deutschland gibt man etwas höherer
kalla punch 71 euro in 2010 ich bin
wirklich mal gespannt ob er auch
wirklich eine 50 euro wert ist bis jetzt
ist er vielleicht zu 20 cent wert sagen
wir mit verpackung 23 sowie kommt zu 30
liter great lakes inc ich glaube man war
das riecht auch schon wieder so nach
papier oder so richtig gut bei mega gut
das war echt lecker und zwar sind hier
in der nummer vier
juli lemonheads das ganze sieht so aus
ziemlich news aber ganz lecker so weit
gekommen so ein affe center schock okay
das muss ich jetzt nicht unbedingt
probieren und jetzt die sechs das ist ja
nikolaus da muss jetzt aber es trotzdem
gibt es ich weiß jetzt nicht ob die mir
das falsche geliefert haben aber ich
habe darauf geachtet oder ich habe genau
den kalender ausgesucht wo nur okay
vielleicht sind es die amerikanische
süßigkeiten weiß ich auch wie die
schmecken mir wahrscheinlich auch so
bekommst du die musik alter nach
seriously strawberry david schon
gespannt welche guckt euch das mal an
warte auch total süß aber schmeckt uns
gut wir kommen zurück
und was ist das
beckett ries schreibt sie die kommentare
sie sollen geil ein mir schmecken die
nicht so das ist dann auch total süß
aber solche release habe ich jetzt auch
noch nie gesehen so leute wir sind schon
bei nummer neun nummern immer gespannt
was in der 24 ist ein trolley bürger
aber das ist ein anderer trolley bürger
früher seien hier noch anders aus ich
habe unseren teil mal so gekommen ich
habe von so zehn stück gegessen griechen
tun die noch leicht das erinnert mich
übelst kraft und irgendwelche
kindergeburtstage mann war so fußball
spielen sondern soccerhalle und es gab
diese ronny berger und deshalb polizei
werfen fußball gespielt toni burger
gestern fußball gespielt bauen
irgendwann war ein so schlecht kann man
verlassen der zehn jungen ist schon
wieder ein herz aber in level könnt ihr
märz schreibt in die kommentare
willkommen duell sieht vor dass in
warhols alter warhead ich weiß nicht ob
er die kennt das sind die saßen bomber
stemmen können mal ausprobieren
wir nehmen hier einfach ein gar nicht
mal so sauer ist wahrscheinlich auf
kinder angepasst schmeckt folgt so wir
kommen zu nummer
fast die hälfte ist geschafft die nummer
12 ist die therapie habe ich vorher auch
noch nie gehört es kann doch keiner
erzählen dass das wirklich so aussehen
soll
das ist bestimmt von geschmolzen dann
wieder zusammen gefroren der laster kam
aus amerika ist durch die wüste gefahren
dann durch die antarktis dann wieder
durch zwar übertrieben
egal wir probieren es jetzt eben
schmeckt aber ganz gut gestylt so wir
kommen zu nummer 13 ist die nummer 13
hier haben nochmal warhead vielleicht
ist das ding
das sieht schon krass das ist ein saures
dinge ich habe einmal den fehler gemacht
und hab einen challenge hausgemacht da
hatte ich eine woche lang mein mund über
zwar jetzt nicht noch mal willkommen zu
nummer 17
[Musik]
es ist das rallyeteam jelly belly ach so
sie sind alle lecker normalerweise gibt
es ja dann so in stinkenden socken
scheiße aber das war alles lecker so
hatten wir schon immer 14
ich glaube nicht mal gucken was die
nummer 14 als nummer 14 ist originals
lemonheads kelley hatten wir auch schon
hier mehr kennenlernen so leute nummer
alter ist dass bislang kein plan was uns
sein soll
sie probieren
boah nicht gut das hat irgendwie so fast
noch gar nicht geschmeckt aber eklig
nummer 16 war dass man sich zehn minuten
hier hast du eigentlich sind
adventskalender dazu gedacht dass man
ihn jeden tag ja jeden tag hat eine
klappe öffnet bei mir was aber früh
recht auch schon so dass ich einfach den
ganzen kalender an einem tag gegessen
habe ich habe damals zu ärger bekommen
so ein schoko kalender ja der war eben
wie dann plötzlich leer
am ersten dezember du keinen plan was
das hier ist sieht nach karamell aus
schmeckt ziemlich geil ich kenne das aus
frankreich ich weiß nicht mehr genau wie
es hieß so leute wir sind vom verein
nummer 20 schon wieder lehmann hält
alter wie viel ändern dadurch 21 schon
wieder jelly beans hey nummer 22 ist
bestimmt ich habe nochmal 19 vergessen
hoppla leute hier haben wir rapid api
das klebt so leute guckt euch das an
warum klebt dass so etwas geht gar nicht
ab das ist locker davon übels lange drin
keine chance ich krieg das sichere haus
nummer 18 habe ich oft vergessen was
geht wieso habe ich das vergessen braid
lemonheads und great etwas ist dass
vieles daraus aber auch nicht so gerne
also es ist wirklich eine
überraschungstüte manches schmeckt gut
manches schmeckt nicht gut ich fertig
bin auf jeden fall mal in der video
beschreibung wenn er bock drauf habt
bitte nummer 21 habe ich die schon okay
bekommen zu nummer zwei
wenn herr cherry leute guckt euch das
mal ein smarter den sinn kämen zusammen
hat robert barry lane hat tropical und
das sieht genauso aus wie lange er so
wir nähern uns langsam dem ende das
letzte fahrt vor der 24 bin so gespannt
was in der 24 ist da musst dir was
geiles hier haben wir bei hätte es
gedacht so leute willkommen zur nummer
24 wirkt als erstes mal gucken jetzt
ohne spaß das ist kein fake ich habe das
nicht vor ausgenommen oder so die 24 ist
erklärt hier wird jemand auf die 24 oder
bin ich jetzt komplett um was ist denn
das für ein kalender war einfach die 24
stellen oder vielleicht ist das irgendwo
hinter gerutscht keine ahnung kann
einmal kurz zerstören
da warte ich auch herausgefunden und ich
hab was gefunden aber als wenn das in
der 24
der suga bubblegum yahoo soll das sonst
drin gewesen sein als wenn wir in die 24
es kann ja sein dass das hier an der
seite unter coach ist aber als wenn er
in die 24 einfach einkaufen geht und
stellt euch mal vor so kleine kinder
haben den ganzen monat einfach auch die
24 hingearbeitet mache dich 24 aufkommen
ich glaube ich hätte früher angefangen
zu weinen naja leute was soll man dazu
sagen ich habe jetzt dafür wirklich
meine meinung zu viel bezahlt deutlich
zu viel
welches video gefallen lassen doch nach
oben da lebten nach oben für die anderen
drei hat wenn es können checkt auf
jedenfalls dann entscheiden wir mal ab
und wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder
worden zum video bezüglich meines autos
haut rein